digital assistants sold by Amazon and
Google are listening possibly even when
you think they are not a consumer
watchdog watchdog organization studied
patent filings for both companies it
says that alexa and rival google home
could start recording more information
than you realize
Jamie yuccas explains how the companies
might use that data that they hear in
the future what's the weather tomorrow
tomorrow in Alhambra you'll see lots of
Sun Elizabeth Saldivar has been relying
on her Amazon echo ever since she got
one as a Christmas gift last year did
you have any concerns when you first got
it
well you know I actually never really
thought about it Google and Amazon the
leading companies that make these
devices say they only record your voice
when you activate them with so-called
wakê words Alexa turn on the hall lights
okay those recordings are then
transmitted back to Amazon and Google
servers where the questions are analyzed
and answered well that's how they work
now some are worried that could change
in the near future they're there to
track you to surveil you and to sell you
the advocacy group consumer watchdog
studied dozens of patent applications
for possible future advances in Google
and Amazon's smart home technology these
patents described is that they're always
watching they're always listening one
amazon patent shows the company could
instruct the echo device to listen for
designated trigger words like a
discussion of vacation destinations it
could then transcribe that conversation
and use it to try to sell the user of
the device a related product I just
think that it's concerning that they
would be able to have access to my
private life a spokesperson for Amazon
tells CBS this morning we do not use
customers voice recordings for targeted
advertising patents take multiple years
to receive and do not necessarily
reflect current developments to products
and services a Google representative
told us consumer watchdogs claims are
unfounded but the claims do point out
how little some consumers know about the
digital gadgets in their homes play
Christmas radio it almost feels a little
bit like
big brother-ish for CBS this morning
Jamie yuccas Alhambra California do you
guys have one of those we do yeah we we
talk to it all the time it doesn't
always respond sometimes it responds
when you're not talking to it too that's
true yeah so are you worried now I'm
constantly worried Gael but it's also
nice to when you're alone to have
something to talk I'm a bit of a shut-in
find that Hardy to work on that Don
doing that hard but it is interesting to
think about that they could be recording
you even when you don't think that they
are I just think just be aware of you
have what in your hand that's all yeah
especially if you have one in your
bedroom be careful